there's just one never left one Ambala
cleveland and i markiplier sorry
hi everybody I'm back there's just one
level left so let's get to it
no need to waste any time because we're
gonna die a lot here we go
my name is right there no it cannot be
that simple
nah boss no it cannot be that now no it
cannot be that simple
it can't be it's all a lie where did I
go wait a minute where did I go what
yeah what
wait okay
I think methinks I didn't actually
complete it yes ah purge ermahgerd
fridge Oh piss okay yeah ah Scott about
that okay this is gonna take a while
oh there's gonna take a while yeah
ah-ha-ha see skies blue house why oh I
don't know how I did that but I did huh
yeah [ __ ] yes alright happy I can't I
don't remember the words yours I would
her burned ah okay I'm if I'm quick
about it right off the bat can I get in
there so I don't ah third no I got a
weight this is no way without it gotta
wait
just be patient something holds me back
on my playthrough huh hahaha is there
another one haha now what I'm to live
ah oh this is gonna this is gonna this
is gonna be bad I hope you guys are
buckled up because this is just gonna be
one law yes why didn't I get on at that
time it's gonna be one long playthrough
that we're not gonna get anywhere close
to finished huh oh ha ha
uh uh or there was another one motivator
I remember it I remember back in my day
we didn't have unfair Mario we had
totally fair Mario why it was almost uh
food did going on Wow okay that's a
possibility I can do that instead
because apparently if I miss that brick
I'm not blown her beer there we go
on there on here then we go up here and
then we can bounce off here and then
here I'm not there hit on the edge of
the one and not the other
Oh piss maybe there's like hang on let
me let me see some here just to like try
to speed things up maybe there's like no
there's no invisible brick there okay so
I just got away nice and patient
herp verb aha yes I got flustered I got
all kinds of flustered
how about said a curse word yet I don't
know I don't care her okay corner oh no
not yet no don't go in no I'm good it's
just a travesty ah come on
ha ha then quarter yeah buddy
and who bounced on top edge I gotta I
can't stop I got to keep the momentum up
or else I won't be able to go so this is
a matter of speed and integrity
boeing-boeing huh boy don't look at me
like that don't look at me like that I
see you all looking at me out there
begging me to be funny and entertaining
I'm angry I'm mad as hell hello take
this anymore huh yeah I'll see what what
the point of that
Oh No hey I almost made a cross there
another demo no one ever how did I make
it almost across before I did I did I
did I saw it but for some reason I'm
unable to get that now okay
Oh hahaha hang on
well I had an idea I might do that same
thing except maybe because I spawned
that brick I wasn't supposed to and it
was off I've done it I've yeah Oh made
it again alright I just gotta go farther
there's a couple avenues that I can take
here but I'm curious hang on I'm just
I'm curious here if I go here and then I
try to woo nope it's there that's why
it's there
cuz it doesn't want you to do that there
is only one way there was only one
method of success perseverance gotta
believe in yourself and what you're
doing
wait a minute why am I doing this I
don't believe probably I don't believe
it all it's all shut up uh-uh
okay I can get there now I know how to
get there dollie
damn Bowser's really stuffed up his game
I'll tell you that shut up Oh I'm a baby
I'm a big baby girl man
I need any like some I need something
just to give me a glimmer of hope that I
can do this could do I go under it no I
do not
so what's the point I'm never gonna be
able to get through there no that
wouldn't work either how am i thinka her
I remember her River if the last level
is like impossible and no one told me
I'm gonna be so upset because this is
just this is just crap that's what this
is that's what this is it is crap
that was my fault I will take full
responsibility for that one and take
whatever traditional action you
disciplinary whatever I don't know I'm
tired of trying to be clever I'm not a
very clever man very simple I like my
games to be easy how the balls do I get
through here oh wait a minute I see a
potential salvation for my soul because
this game has sucked it out I must
recover it no why Mario stop greasing
your feet gah lis
it's all that crazy Italian food stop it
you Japanese Italian plumber freak Oh
Cass op never mind now on Falls toe they
all fall I gotta find a way to go up but
I can't it's impossible it's impossible
it's impossible I own
oh no it's probably an avenue that I
haven't even seen yet it's like
invisible bricks here and fudge me why I
was able to survive that oh wait a
minute
wait wait wait that's why they were
that's why they were brick nah but I'm
on to something I know I know I know I
know you're all like God God mark and
I'm like I know I see it - I'm here
playing it and you all forget you're in
the future I'm in the past you got all
you future people you're all the same
take what we have for granted learn from
the mistakes of your elders and your
Markab liars
okay so yep this is what happens ah no
I'll get it I'll get is I make mistakes
so far and there's probably not a single
checkpoint on this entire ding dong damn
map well what the tension Magoo I swear
I have picked poorly in my game
selection
I picked very poorly wish Wow okay
you're all yes yes yes yes yes now go
get back yes No ah so close that the
only spike on there that better be the
only spike on there I will be shell
pierced if it we're near peed presiden
paper didn't break with the graph there
are no speed no precision I had speed
the precision was gone
Oh done her done sweet virgin do a girl
training girl career no you know pass I
wasn't even paying attention I'm not
even in the same game huh I'm trying to
make other references to things I don't
I don't even I don't even have any
authority to talk about God the margin
of errors so small I'm gonna lose my
mind I'm gonna lose my mind I'm not even
gonna make sound effects anymore
no no sound effects ah no this is my
life this is my life why can't I make
this jump ah okay come on just make it
back buddy
ha yes uh-huh oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh oh don't [ __ ] up
yes yes oh god now alive ha ha ha
damn it ah I'm so angry how I'm from
Eiling but I'm not I'm not
whoa gotta get enough speed yes go join
your match well my blood pressures gone
through the roof I'm not about to bust
an artery in my forehead
kupah ha ha ha ha oh man why can I not
make this jump on a consistent basis
yeah ha ha I am Alive come on I'm really
trying I'm really trying here I'm really
I really am I'm really trying I'm trying
very hard like this isn't just like Nam
nice is she's not really fuse like gonna
try but I'm actually really trying to
win here but not go oh oh those double
spikes I've never seen you before
uf right oh my god it please tell me ha
ha ha it's hopeless
my whole method it's hopeless I can't
make that jump I was a mile off my whole
life is a lie everything I've done is
meaningless torn down like the pillars
of society ah ok um I never pick this up
I may never beat it could take me hours
be good for a live stream just six
straight hours of me playing this yeah
that sounds good for my sanity
so anyway oh god I don't even know the
method of doing it and I haven't looked
up another person beating it so I don't
know how to do it so that's all the time
I got for now so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done then as always
I'll see you in the next video bye bye
you
nah
Oh
but
put it here